foreign
the debt ceiling of the U.S we have
apparently hit our credit limit
Christina and there's a lot of fears of
defaulting on this debt and the treasury
has begun what they're calling
Extraordinary Measures whoa whoa juicy
stuff oh so what's going on
man it's interesting so it looks like we
have hit this debt ceiling and there's
debates now one side wants spending cuts
the other side doesn't want to budge
y'all it feels a little bit like the
government right now is like a drunk at
the bar who ran out of their credit card
limit and people are saying no you can't
spend anymore and they found one more
credit card in their pocket and they're
like hey everyone drinks on me oh boy
yeah so the amount of time the
department can continue taking steps to
avoid defaulting on the debt unless the
31.381 trillion limit is raised is
uncertain and so if you're wondering
what this refers to it's the maximum
amount of the US government can spend on
its existing obligations so think things
like Social Security military salaries
food stamps uh things like that and
they're voting to raise the debt ceiling
uh but the question Christina that
you're raising is the Republicans are
saying hey if you're going to raise this
thing you better cut the spending bucko
and the Democrats are saying no no hey
don't put strings attached on this let's
just raise it guys be cool be cool I'm
like this is the opposite of a zero
based budget they're basically running
on a negative budget oh yeah I'm like
can we can we go up to Washington and
and help them budget is that possible if
you ever want just a lot of a lot more
anxiety in your life you can go to
usdeckclock.org and it has running
numbers for all of the debts and uh it's
nothing like that so much red oh it's
not pretty and so this is something the
US has never done defaulting on its debt
which puts us in a really precarious
situation globally because other
countries are saying hey you guys said
you were good for the money and this is
like defaulting on your student loan
payment you can't pay this is scary it's
scary and I want to kind of use this
conversation we were planning on doing
an update on student loans anyways we've
had a lot of people asking about
forgiveness and what are the latest
updates and so I kind of want to use
this conversation to go into student
loan forgiveness okay so right now now
it's supposed to go the Forgiveness plan
is supposed to go before The Supreme
Court on February 28th the White House
has said that borrowers will resume
payments 60 days after the court cases
have been resolved and if the courts
have not resolved the issue by June 30th
payments will resume 60 days after that
and I saw something really interesting
in an article by Business Insider it
said Congress did not increase funding
for the federal student aid office in
the latest spending Bill suggesting
hurdles to come with implementation of
these reforms the administration said
that the department is disappointed with
a lack of funding and notes that it will
present a challenge
yeah so uh summary it's not looking good
it's not like if you're hoping for
student loan forgiveness it sounds like
it's going to be more uphill battles
more fighting more standstill gridlock
over uh at the White House in Congress
and I know that's stressful for a lot of
people
a lot of friends a lot of people in my
life who have been very excited for
student loan forgiveness they have
breathed major size of relief over the
last year it was going to allow them to
get debt free so I'm not really rooting
one way or another you know I think it's
just frustrating in general that there's
been so much drag in this there's been
so much political turmoil over this and
we just want to say that if you have
student loan debt right now it's really
important that you start thinking
through how you're going to pay this off
I would not count on this the US is
saying right now that it's out of money
it's running at a deficit you know and
it's not increasing the budget for
student aid so there's a lot of
complications in this I'm not saying
it's impossible I mean obviously it
could technically happen they could get
another debt extension but I wouldn't
count on it I would not count on
Washington and all of this mess going on
right now to forgive your debt I would
start working and creating a plan
yourself get control of your money don't
wait until June 30th don't wait till you
know September whenever these payments
come back to start thinking about it for
the first time and if anything right now
start paying on it because there's not
interest accruing this is the best time
to be paying off this debt you are not
accruing interest so use this as
motivation don't use this as fear use it
as motivation to get into control of
your finances to take ownership of your
money don't leave that control to people
who are literally running a negative
budget that is a scary situation but you
don't have to be scared you can follow a
budget you can carve out room for your
student loan payment and not only that
you can carve out room to get ahead
yeah this whole situation feels like
you're asking your broke friend who's
about to go through bankruptcy to cover
your tab and the dude's got no money and
so with the US defaulting on a threat it
makes it even more unlikely that they're
going to have funding for the student
loan forgiveness program and
um if the if the government does default
on this it could cause the financial
markets to tank it could hurt 401ks
other Investments it could hurt the
overall economy the GDP of this country
and so it's definitely a a scary
situation and the best thing to do is
focus on what you can control because if
the dollar loses a little bit of its
value but I still have a bunch of money
in the bank and I don't owe anyone
anything I can still sleep better at
night right when I see something like
this instead of being like Oh gloom and
doom this is scary everything's going to
poo I'm like what can I do with my
family and my fan finances to tighten up
how can I save a little bit more
aggressively if you have debt making
sure you pay off that debt use it as
motivation to get even more gazelle
intents to press in and control what you
can control